the kia optima history manual Schaefer
describes the kia optima as handsome and
the design awards it's one back him up
now we're going on a little test drive
to check out the rest of it if I figured
the ride starts before the engines even
running Amanda while Schaefer pushes the
start button the driver's seat
automatically lose into the right
position the disadvantage is that when
he turns the car off the seat moves back
again that's hard to get used to chew on
Vantage alstonville feathers it's nine
lessons at fasken ruining food or fish
the Optima is kia's mid-range entry to
hold its own against the German market
leaders it sports a German design and an
engine developed by opel that does help
overcome some of the key is spotty
reputation the Kia does some things
quite well but not everything
d'alençon amano says the optimist
steering is a bit mushy you don't get
much feedback from the road to guide you
they could have made it a bit tighter
item on flesh and mean stuff options or
the optimist interior is done in
materials that have a nice look and feel
to them
the navigation system is directed toward
the driver the dashboard layout is clear
and well organized the driver's seat can
remember two settings but there's still
some room for improvement the tank man
whoa says he likes the feel of the wheel
but the glossy finish seems out of place
the design by Peter Schreyer of Germany
stands out with its Ice Cube LED running
lights and glossy black trim the
contours are streamlined and guaranteed
to turn heads
the rear hints at a sport sedan with its
angular taillights and spoiler lip
postponed Tazawa te manawa gives the Kia
Optima points for comfortable seats and
a suspension that's not too hard and not
too soft so even a long drive on holiday
would be manageable without doing you in
a button opens the trunk that has 500 5
liters of cargo space 25 more than a
Mercedes c-class and it's expandable but
the opening is narrow which makes
loading harder further forward it can
get a bit tight man well satisfied with
the Headroom but says taller people
might have some problems with it the
seat can't be set any lower it's a minor
flaw uncle the car we tested comes in at
121 kilowatts with a top speed of 210
km/h the Optima is rated at 162 grams of
co2 emissions per kilometre at seven
litres per 100 kilometers consumption is
high especially given the sluggishness
of the engine
it owns I'm testifying aman allah says
the two liter gasoline engine and his
test car had rather poor pick up when he
stepped on the gas it took the engine
forever to get up to speed it didn't
really kick in properly until it hit
3,000 rpms for [ __ ] enough constant what
I forget so what's the overall verdict
nothing missing after some time behind
the wheel of Kia Optima he has a feel
for its pluses and minuses one clear
point in its favor is price this
top-of-the-line model starts at thirty
one thousand euros that wouldn't even
get you a basic Mercedes c-class awesome
the Optimus base model starts at just
under twenty five thousand euros in
Germany eight thousand less than an
entry model Mercedes c-class so if you
like the feel and don't mind the high
fuel consumption the kia optima may well
be a contender